を超えていくから
食べ物は全然大丈夫でしたか?
そうね、あの 最初に学校の寄宿舎に入れられたときはちょっとやっぱり
何が困ったっていうのはないんですけど、ちょっと慣れるのに時間がかかりましたね
お昼と晩と両方急に学校になっちゃって、だからちょっと大変だったけど
もちろん3食フラン
朝はパンとバターだけなの、それとカフェオレがこんな大きいので
入院したときに3時のおやつ、飲み物が出るけど
何を飲むかって聞かれて、何があるの?って言ったら
紅茶とミルクと
入院なさったの?
はい
大変でしたね
夜寝る前も、9時に何か寝る前に飲むかってきて、何があるの?って
ハーブティーと、なんとかちょっと、あ、ちゃん、ハーブティー、ハーブティーって
一応体験しておこうと思って
病院食も肉にするか、魚にするかって聞かれました
うん
すごい
っていう
いきなり食べちゃうんですね、肉も魚も
うん、なんか聞かれたから、じゃあ肉?とか
あははは
うん
3時のおやつ、全部、全部飲み物も聞かれて
自分で日本人だと、いや何でもいいですとか、なんかそれだとダメなんですよね
うん
私はココアが欲しいとか、うん
なんかちゃんと自分で主張しないと
うん
それが外国のね、文化としては
あ
よかったら取って、回して
これいただきます
どう?
そして
うん
チェイちゃん
一つ、一ついただきます
ありがとう
イシカはどうですか?
ん?
いやいやもう大丈夫だ
はい、じゃあこれ一ついただきます
はい、こちらへ
はい、ありがとうございます
あの、ジンジャエルどっちがいいですか?
あ、ありがとうございます
おいしい、ジンジャエル
これ、作るのないの?
あ、これ作るの?
これ、作るの?これ、口付けてないから
あ、いやいやいや
さっきのお茶、そこでいただいたのもおいしかった
本当にお聞き?
ふだたさんもジンジャエル入れますか?
あ、そうですか、じゃあジンジャエル
おいしいジンジャエル